[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my chat
my conversation my chinwag with the
incredible incredible I don't say that
lightly Stephen pressfield whose book
amongst others his book The War of art
has absolutely transformed and changed
my life and countless other people and
creative people who are trying to do
their calling to follow their Bliss to
write that book to write that script to
write that song to start that physical
transformation whatever it is Stephen
pressfield wrote this book to help you
get over what he calls resistance or the
resistance it came about because I
texted Ryan holiday I was like I don't
know what's going on man I've had this
movie idea for almost 10 years I just
can't write it I I know it it's outlined
I I have interest I want to do it but I
can't sit down and do it and he said
read the war of art I listen to it on
tape on tape you know
and I'm almost done with it I mean I
read it it's exactly the kick in the
pants that I needed the gentle loving
kick in the pants and I'm off to the
races I'm almost done so this is going
to be a book that I've already listened
to twice and I will always go back to
whenever I need that boost to get it
done and if you guys have a project like
that you are going to benefit from this
conversation deeply I know I did it's
incredible he also has a new book out
called government cheese g o v t cheese
which is incredible it's his Memoir I'm
loving that as well he has other books
going pro which is also incredible just
check them out but especially the war of
art give it a read especially if you
have a project that you've wanted to get
off the ground and you just couldn't so
check them out and you're going to enjoy
this chat just a couple things to plug
up top I have some tour dates where am I
going to be I'm going to be this is when
I found out where I'm going to be Denver
that's going to be awesome St Louis
Raleigh North Carolina Salt Lake City
we're adding more and more dates to
petehomes.com I know I'm going to be
coming to Indiana soon
so whenever you listen to this just go
to petehomes.com chances are I will be
touring and coming to a town near you
hope you can be there and those of you
that are new to the show you might not
know this but we only do ads for things
that I actually use and actually love
and these Pete's picks at the top of the
show are absolute OG Pete's picks magic
mind you guys know I talk about magic
mine a lot I'm always offering it to the
guests why because I want them to be on
their game for the show and when I am
feeling sluggish creatively drained a
little fatigued having a hard time
thinking focusing dialing in Magic mine
is a magical Elixir that helps me focus
better helps you focus better on your
work be more creative and drink less
coffee athletes have Gatorade now
creators have creatorade it is a mix of
12 functional ingredients including
matcha new atropics that help you focus
and adaptogens that help you fight off
stress so it sort of rounds the edges of
your coffee so you can drink it with
your coffee or by itself it doesn't make
you wired it gets you dialed in 30
percent more stuff done on average five
to seven hours of thirty percent more
productivity after drinking fighting off
procrastination brain fog fatigue and
some ADD symptoms getting you into that
flow State I love it I find it mood
elevating I find it really really
helpful when I need to dig in and do
work answer emails or write it's
incredible and I have an amazing offer
for weirdos from our friends at
magicmind all you have to do is go to
magicmind.com
weird and use my discount code at
checkout weird for a limited 20 off
that's magicmine.com weird and use
discount code weird for twenty percent
off your first order I swear I swear by
it and I hope you love it too we're also
brought To Us by our friends at Living
libations for years I've been mindful
about what I put in my body but a couple
years ago I realized I wasn't being
careful about what I put on my body
which of course ends up in your body I
was buying shaving cream and face washes
that I thought were good because they
had fancy French names and solded null
kiosks but of course these things are
filled with chemicals linked to disease
and toxicity levels never intended for
human skin or your body then I realized
I want to eat food where I recognize the
ingredients and I want my skin care to
be the same enter living Libations not
only the best and most effective skin
care hot hair eyes teeth and baby care
products I have found but also the most
natural you're not making compromise
it's badass effective powerful stuff and
it's natural made exclusively with
plants and oils and extracts that not
only will you recognize but you'll be
able to easily pronounce and now that
it's summer having a natural zinc based
sunblock for Leela is so important and
so many of the ones that I see online
just aren't there love the sun sunblock
not only works and lasts a really really
long time both the bottle lasts a long
time but also lasts on your skin a long
time we can feel great about putting it
on ourselves and on our baby all summer
long so this is a great way to support
the show get something small get
something big either way you will be
showing your love and your support of
this show and your body some love as
well go to
livinglibations.com weird for 15 off
that's livinglibations.com weird alright
everybody enjoy the wonderful chat with
the wonderful Stephen pressfield get
into it I had a talk show and this is
what that's from uh-huh doesn't have fun
yeah
so we just we just repurposed it
okay we're rolling
there's no real
formality you can just hold it like
you're eating an ice cream that's that's
the tip okay how are you I'm good how
are you Pete we've just met through Ryan
holiday yeah we did you know over email
that's right so that's great he's
introduced me to a lot of great authors
and and just great people and we tend to
be drawn to similar people and he's
really drawn to you he loves you he
keeps posting about it I love him too
he's yeah he's a great guy and he's
taught me a lot I'll tell you for
somebody that's like 40 years younger
than me or whatever isn't that annoying
yeah that is annoying when does he do
all that writing yeah yeah some people
just have a compulsion it seems to me
like I I don't mean it like bad
compulsion I mean like I think he's
compulsed
to write like I don't think
you know it's interesting reading your
work I'm reading government cheese right
now but also war of Art and some of your
other things it's like
what does it feel like to not write
always comes up to me like especially in
government she's you know I'm reading
what it was I'm just making sure this is
off I'm reading what it was like before
you found your flow and found your
purpose it's really interesting to hear
all the all the shame and the guilt and
the question I mean did you were you
immediately a comic like straight out of
high school or something don't you do
this well it's funny I've been thinking
I'm writing a joke about anxiety right
now
and the the Crux of it is everybody
complains about too much anxiety and I
get it but nobody's nobody's screaming
the virtues of just the right amount of
exactly and I want to write a joke about
the I only really have the opening line
as I go I have anxiety thank God
I understand it's a bell curve too much
is debilitating but not enough no that's
that's good is numb but I'm gonna ask
you about that I know I'm supposed to be
interviewing but I know it's okay go
ahead when you say you're writing it is
a day off
you are a day off I'm so excited to talk
to you I don't I don't feel pressured or
beholden when I have a Day writing a
joke tell me you say when you say you're
writing a joke yes you make it sound
like it's going to take you three weeks
or a month or something I mean is it
just is a joke like this joke will it be
like a setup line and a punch line
that's the whole thing
or will it be a whole what will it be I
think you could do it as well if you
have an area that you are deeply
passionate about so I when I was young
starting as a comic I knew I had a joke
when I had something clever that would
uh literally almost like a like a trap
you set in the woods like it's a hair
trigger and you'll go in it and it'll
snap and it'll close you so an example
of that would be
um I bought a paper shredder it's an old
joke of mine
um I love that my paper chair came with
a manual because that's the first to go
that's just a joke
um it gets better after that I go I just
plugged in the shredder put in the
manual like if this doesn't shred I'll
read it it's clever it's a joke that's a
setup I bought a shredder and a
punchline it's actually two lines anyway
now just like you and I'm assuming
you're thinking of things you can write
about
I get a white light in my belly of I
couldn't forget this if I tried I write
it down not to remember it I write it
down to exercise it from my body and
when I go on stage I have don't don't
forget to talk about anxiety but I
didn't have to like try to remember I
have anxiety thank God that's how I feel
uh-huh it's like writing the music you
know and I go and I I can go on stage
it gets a little tricky as to whether or
not I can yank if I can fish at the
whole audience over my shoulder like
Santa Claus and bring them with me on
that feeling that's where the the craft
comes in but the identification of what
a joke is now comes from a strong
feeling which often isn't funny it's
just a deeply excited uh
urgent feeling and to answer my own
question and to put it back to you when
I don't let those things out and then
share them it feels like too much
anxiety ah it'll Fester like a pond and
get scummy and gross and unclear but if
I keep it moving and passing I'm
definitely a believer in that yeah yeah
but you know when you were talking about
I have anxiety thank God yeah that could
be a book
that could be a book the size of the war
of art or something like that 190 Pages
yeah yeah you could do an entire thing
really I haven't actually yeah nobody's
done it you know in defense of anxiety
yeah really yeah yeah that's I well it's
a concept that's a very sweet I love
that compliment and I'm like you I I
want to find I think I'm like you and
that you just did this I want to find
what the joke where the joke belongs the
best like where the idea excuse me
sometimes a joke is a joke sometimes
it's a movie sometimes it's a book
sometimes it's a cartoon like I found I
submitted some cartoons to the New
Yorker because I was like that's that
just is a New Yorker cartoon so you had
to did you get accepted I did it took
about a year
I think it's something like four or five
hundred bucks per cartoon why not yeah
you have to break it down yeah to the
time no well I guess that answers why
I'm not still doing it I think if you
get on contract is because you seem like
an interested person yeah if you get a
contract with them it's more money if
you're just freelancing it reminds me of
your story hacking together little gigs
and finding your place here yeah but but
here now I am going to put it to you
I told you that when I don't create and
share and reflect and and be reflected
too that like beautiful circle of
sharing it's not just narcissism me
saying I like anxiety and they're just
they also feed it back to me and the
feedback and the laughs and the groans
and the and the silence it's this it's
this beautiful dialogue and it makes me
feel connected and alive and safe it
makes me feel safe these people
understood me so you in your book uh
government cheese uh govt she is because
because the government doesn't look
right government spelled out I agree
yeah government yeah yeah you're not
here to govern the cheese
covered cheese
but you write about this I love you use
the word feckless because it's just such
a great word
um because it sounds like a bad word but
it's not
uh your early years I was really struck
with how many times you called yourself
a loser because there's part of me that
like my heart sort of
connected and broke for young Stephen
and this is kind of before you found
your path would you talk a little bit
about what it feels like before you
found look at your Xanax what are you
doing you you deepen your words right
now what's happening yeah go ahead yeah
what does it feel like to not create
isn't that why you create because it
feels better than not creating uh
see if I can let's see if I can get this
right like I sort of
started what sort of put me on this
downward spiral this loser spiral was as
a young uh writer copywriter at an ad
agency as in the book yeah I had a boss
who wrote a novel that was a hit or an
overnight hit he became an overnight
chocolate and popsicles chocolate days
popsicle weeks by Ed Hannibal you can
look it up it was a good book can I also
say when you said that I had a nice
perspective where I was like here you
are young Stephen going chocolate days
and popsicle nights imagine if I could
be the guy that wrote chocolate days and
popsicle nights and here we are in 2023
going like what and what like it's so
ethereal it fades yeah it's true all
goes away yeah yeah but okay so I try I
said well [__] how hard can it be yeah
let me let me write one too so I just
sort of totally was over my head and the
whole thing crashed my marriage blew up
blah blah blah because of the book
because of the book because I didn't
finish the book because I crapped out at
the end
Etc and other things that I was writing
the book Jeopardy because I was
interested you're very you're almost
like Hemingway you're very tight
succinct masculine so you're going bang
bang I couldn't finish the book I got
99.9 of the way and then I sabotaged
myself and Leslie and I fell apart and
I'm over here going like I love it I
wouldn't change a thing but now that I'm
talking to you I'm like was it the
writing of the book or was it the not
finishing of the book that really fudged
those are not finishing of it it was a
sort of the failure of uh being a good
husband the failure of being a provider
the failure of being a man that kind of
thing right and uh so I forgot even what
the question was we were talking about
we're talking about what it felt like to
not write yeah oh so I felt like a
complete loser at that point yeah and
and I was you know in in certainly in my
wife's eyes and my eyes and my family's
eyes and the next thing I knew I was
sort of on the road I sort of fell out
of the bottom of the middle class and
and uh you know there was such a a stink
of defeat about me that like if I went
in for a to apply for a white collar job
you know people would like get nervous
just sitting across something you got a
vibration yeah exactly you know I mean
it sounds like a joke but it's not I and
believe in this so hard let's not
Sidetrack too much but I just want to
yes and your premise there's ruts we get
into and I like vibration because it's
like the the subtle way you're shaking
yeah starts telling people almost like a
predator or almost like a sound in the
world because instinctual as those
things we go I can't I told my therapist
that that somebody in my family was
having a hard time getting getting a
therapist and he was like everyone I
called would turn me down and my
therapist goes yeah I do that all the
time you can just tell there's something
about it I never thought about that
that's true I was like I thought you had
to see everybody he's like no Pete
there's some people you just go like not
me yeah let's start somewhere else so
that's where I was us that's who I was
that's the groove I was in and so
the next thing I knew the only jobs I
could get were the kind of blue collar
jobs that all you have to have is a
pulse yeah to get the job you know like
working in oil fields or working in a
mental hospital or something like the
movie The Master uh no I didn't oh God
run I've heard of it yeah good it just
reminds me of the of the the character
the lead character Joaquin Phoenix's
character is very feckless and taking
these pulse jobs like he's harvesting
cabbages and you're just like yeah this
guy
very lost that's a real world that's
very lost so you definitely at that time
feel like a loser and everything
reinforces that yeah you're losing at
Western capitalist success yeah yeah
you're thinking about your classmates
from high school or from college or
whatever where they are yeah they're
married they have children they have
jobs blah blah blah blah blah and you
don't so but at the same time I knew
because I had what had started this for
me was not finishing a book I knew the
only way for me to get out of this is at
some point I've got to sit down and
write something you know this sound like
a story from the Old Testament or like a
myth it does it's like the prodigal son
or something like that right you know
well you got broken and had to go back
home to yourself but I think it's true
really truly Pete for like
everybody I think goes through I'm doing
a little thing on Instagram now about
um what I call a Passage through the
Wilderness which I think a lot of us
have right we fall out of we have a
period of Our Lives where we're really
in the wilderness right we we we're
addicted to something we're in jail
we're just all screwed up or whatever it
is and how do you how you come out of it
is by facing whatever the demon was that
put you into the Wilderness in the first
place that's right so you know like if
somebody wanted to be a stand-up comic
but they were afraid to get on stage and
so they went off into some other you
know other dimension other path of Life
yeah they would and they were miserable
they started drinking Etc they whatever
yeah they would know [__] I gotta get on
that stage at some point yes I gotta
face the music right this is was there
anything in am I ringing any kind of
bells with doing all sorts of bells oh
absolutely so I grew up in a household
that was incredibly loud and unstable
and a lot of fighting and I hated it and
then I said and alcohol was involved and
then I got into a profession where it's
my job I was incapable of settling down
these Greek gods these Giants
[__] scary sitting tense meals
then I got into a job where's my job to
go out in front of drunk people and
settle
D what is that that's circling back to
the dragon and finding incredible
satisfaction out of like not this Dad
not this mom [__] you it's great it's
incredible so absolutely but you also
rang about I just um I don't I hope you
like the movie bag events I know you
wrote the book so I'm sure you have some
Stephen King shining feelings about it
but I rewatched that movie uh because I
love that movie I I was at a great age
when that movie came out and going back
to it it was just so comforting and
beautiful oh really so yeah I really
like it have you read the book I haven't
read the book well you should read the
book yeah yeah here's the author
I know from what little I know about you
the themes in there will ring back I
believe it you're just seeing
embarrassment and I'm talking yeah so
many of your other things but no I will
I I'm glad I'm just I'm just noting if
you saw a little flutter in her cheeks
I'm just embarrassed
um but that movie uh we uh that story
Matt Damon's character uh Juno Juno
Randolph Jr yeah Juno uh they say Juno
so many times in that movie I was like
Juno there's a lot of jokes anyway he
also he runs away from his calling
because the war of life and he gets into
drinking the war literally and he gets
away from his calling and then he has to
come back to it and he's garbage at it
but it's the it's the pattern you're
describing yeah which is which I was
totally unaware of when I was working on
it no kidding tell me what do you mean
you just stumbled on it well I you know
um all right have you heard of I'm gonna
get wonky here on you but that's what I
want to do right here are you familiar
with the Hindu scripture the
bhagavad-gita so
Bagger Vance is stole the plot of the
bhagavad-gita which is to get this is I
hope our listeners you have no idea
where you are you're in the safest place
to talk about this so he's Arjuna so
yeah
I mean one of the one of the titles of
respect for Krishna as I'm sure you know
is bhagavan yeah so that becomes bag or
Vance you know magavan meaning Lord yeah
so the the whole story of uh of the Gita
is the great warrior Arjuna laying down
his arms refusing to fight on the eve of
a great battle because they're all his
relatives all his relatives are teachers
yeah right and his charioteer happens to
be Krishna I.E God in human form yeah
and so Krishna sort of uh it's a mentor
Protege story where he sort of teaches
you know Arjuna about Duality and
non-duality Karma previous lives all
these great yeah you know Hindu
Christian rules right yeah and
obligations and etc etc so Juna Arjuna
is a
in other words that was sort of where I
was coming as far as coming from as far
as structuring the story rather than
thinking about it in that in that other
way which I didn't think about it at all
but you were smart enough to know that
there are brilliant stories like the
prodigal son that touch on a quick
believer in stealing from great stories
are you crazy Romeo and Juliet whatever
you don't go for it they're doing all
this great leg work for you it's like
learning from your elders it's the same
exact thing it's not theft it's almost
out of respect yeah right it's not it's
not stealing if you put a spin on it but
jokes as well right absolutely well it
used to be over there but we got Steve
Martin all these people whose albums I
absorbed you'd be insane to think that I
just went up yeah and talk like this the
way I'm talking to you right now this is
not oh my talk this is how I learned how
to talk by listening to people that I
admired absolutely that's so interesting
and I was just by the way talking about
the the bhagavad-gita last night really
yes last night so not 12 hours ago my
friend Genevieve was like we were
talking about Arjuna not wanting to
fight in the battle and Krishna
basically being like it's the only thing
to do like you can do it or not do it
but like it's kind of what's Happening
that's like a very you know Silly
summary but that's very similar to the
line forgive me if you've heard that I'm
sure a billion but just forgive me
um it's the it's the game that can't be
won or lost but can only be played right
which is you know
where does that come from is that from
some uh that's in your book it is get
out of here that's you I quoted you to
you really unless wow I haven't read
this better than I thought huh it's in
the movie it's got to be in the book I
don't know if it is anyway maybe we'll
give credit to Jeremy Levin the
screenwriter oh no edit that out we'll
give him no credit that was you
but I feel that way I've never even
played golf and but I see
you know you're doing this I'm doing
this it's so it's also kind of
like I was at a tea ceremony recently
have you ever done one of those no I
never have I've read about them I've
never seen one or never been married to
you I had only heard old Alan Watts
talking about how meaningful they were
and what really struck me as we did
round after round of T just in silence
very deliberately drinking tea
it struck me how absurd it was and I
think that might have been the point for
me that day in the same way that golf is
absurd
doing this interview
that's what the person said life is
absurd right life is absurd and isn't
that kind of what Krishna is saying yeah
like you can probably do it anyway you
can opt out but are you really
opting out because like reading your
book government cheese and all the like
little houses that you rent on the side
of the road and I there's a there's a I
don't know if it's masculine but there's
a part of every man that I know that
would be like that sounds great you know
you just go off and you live in a little
cinder block house and just kind of
don't [__] by the way thanks for reading
it because you certainly didn't have to
you know I'm enjoying it skimmed it or
done whatever thanks for reading I'm
enjoying the hell out and you're a great
writer and I'm it's fun to see the other
side of you because we'll get to the war
of art ah but I was thinking about
that and what a cop-out that could be to
like if Arjuna decided to not fight in
the war yeah it's like okay yeah yeah
but that was just a millisecond in the
story and you didn't do anything it
would have been better to be a villain
you know what I mean I'm not saying we
should be villains but at least you're
doing something yeah right yeah you're
playing the game yeah well that's in
that's in the ramayana is the bad guy is
is really the good guy in Disguise
because he's moving the story along and
when you see that I don't know about it
you're educated there you go let's get
Hindu baby let's go when you start to
see
I'm talking too much but like I had a
conflicting morning like my daughter was
just stressing me out she didn't want
any of the break I made her for
breakfast it was in today this morning
this morning I was very happy to be
talking with you because I was like this
is I need to get out of the house you
need another like you're you're you have
a good
I don't know how to say it but like a
masculine voice in my Consciousness
but then as I was driving here I was
grateful for that conflict even though
as it's happening I'm like this is the
worst thing in the world because I was
like at least something's happening and
I'm more used to The Listener and I'm
more used to you honestly because I can
tell you like it was deeply frustrating
like lost my cool as much as I don't
want to do that that's where my humanity
is like Leonard Cohen the cracks or how
the light gets through and now I'm so
much more alive and present here because
I failed this morning what good is
Superman give me Batman ah interesting
all right hit me with whatever that gave
you
um or I can take you back to the story
you were telling me what you just said
take me back to the story I was just
telling whatever yeah I'm gonna try to
calm down I'm talking a lot and I want
you to talk a lot
uh you we were talking about you uh what
it felt like when you don't write and
what when you went from feckless to
finding your voice and we were already
covered Leslie and your your thing blew
up let me I'll break in here because you
said something before that I think will
ring bells between the two of us ring it
if you don't write and let's use that as
a metaphor for whatever for all of the
other things that people might do if you
have a great joke on your mind then you
don't follow through on it
it that's not a benign action you know
that Joe that Unwritten joke
goes into a bad Channel inside you and
becomes I'm absolutely convinced of this
and becomes cancer you know it becomes
something like it's must get out it's
like a living thing like it like if
we're if we're female and we're giving
birth and we're pregnant and you cross
your life it's a living thing that's
inside us like the alien yeah you know
yeah that's gotta get out and until it
gets out nothing good happens well we're
back to rivers and ponds right flow is
else Pond is not yes so you're saying
and I completely agree but for those
listening we have these ideas you're
talking about the risk of no risk we
think there's taking a risk yeah
quitting the job writing the book not
going to the Fourth of July thing so you
can sit and write or whatever it might
be but you go that's a risk I'll miss
out on all those things by the way are
very short-term gains I'll have a hot
dog I'll laugh with my friends yeah not
that I I don't give in to plenty of
those of course me too but there's the
risk of not risking and that those those
are heavy risks you're saying that
stagnation can manifest and I would
agree with this in depression and
disease exactly I think it absolutely
does yeah and and look and the opposite
side of that is if you do follow through
with the joke yeah health comes you know
something positive something where you
feed around the ground something where
you feel like well I'm doing what I was
put here to do yes and I can sleep
tonight you know yes flow
finding or even not flow even grinding
it out you know well that I like about I
see I'm one of these writers that
you've helped me get more in touch with
the romance or the reality maybe of of
suffering at the at the computer like
there's something that really stood out
in the war of art where it's like you
you were I forget how long your work day
mine is about four hours three hours me
too yeah okay and I'm like
when I got nothing done but at least I
was just looking at the page and nothing
got done but you go okay it's uh two
o'clock I'm done was the work good it
doesn't matter that's my impression
doesn't matter at least you got in there
when about my wife is reading it um I
don't know if you know the Enneagram but
she's an Enneagram 9.
Enneagram I'm actually an Enneagram get
the [__] out no not that I know what it
means I just did it once I love it here
my girlfriend Diana is big into the
Enneagram okay what is she she's done
and she's a four see I'm a four and
she's a nine these are great combos we
go I got good good feelings for you and
your girlfriend wonderful pairing so Val
is Nine's all you need to know is
Jamaica they're the beach people it's
not that all of Jamaica is that way but
it's like relax we just want no conflict
no stress so it's very but a nine in
health is a three which is the achiever
which is gonna go out and ring the bell
and prove it I didn't know that so
you're a healthy nine ah and Val is a
healthy 90 but she's reading your book
uh by my uh recommendation and when I
summarize it I just go stop being a
candy ass
and just get in there so the line is was
the word good was it not good it doesn't
matter you did it that was it very
profound which actually in many ways is
sort of if if when I die if there's any
lesson that comes out of this you know
it's so true I mean it really sort of
Saved Me is
like I say when I sit down to write in a
day
I really don't judge myself at all on
did I do anything good did I get 500
words or whatever is all I say to ask
myself is did I put in the time and did
I try hard and if I did then I Pat
myself on the back and I say Okay that
was a good day yeah yeah and and I think
really you know I'm a Believers you know
in the Muse and the goddess and I think
that when she looks down on us you or me
or whoever it sees us putting in the
time even if there's nothing on the page
at the end of the day that counts you
know that goes in the book you know her
book yeah her book of you're a good boy
yeah you know and because you were
available you tried all you can do is
try right yeah you know it's like you
had the channel like a ham radio like
you had it on the frequency nobody
called you yeah but that's on them yeah
you were there and then it seems to me
to continue with that the Muse goes oh
this guy's radio is open maybe I'll
start sending him yeah exactly some
messages you know they say like in uh in
training in the gym whatever it is that
not every day is going to be a good day
yeah and it's you know in fact it's rare
when it's a good day a lot of days are
going to be shitty days you don't really
do it but you're it's a day you did the
day you know and that's all you can ask
of yourself can you go did you have more
no that's it uh I ran out again no no
you know that's all I just don't want to
cut you off I
we talk about this a lot on this podcast
I think it's this strange mechanism of
this universe that just seeking pleasure
and avoiding pain doesn't work but most
people we're going back to those goals
like okay I could sit and write or
pursue my whatever
or go to the Fourth of July barbecue we
all do like short-term things that's one
but we also just like would rather avoid
pain sitting in the chair is going to be
pain
we do that more than we do to gain
pleasure
I wonder what that makes you think of
but also the fact that like we always
talk about heroin heroin doesn't work
isn't that crazy isn't it weird that
there's nothing on this planet like that
that works meaning it will take a toll
it's it's sort of a crazy it's almost
like a trick that God played on that's
what you know like the if it's
short-term satisfaction if it's
immediate in gratification it's gonna
kill you buddy but the long-term
satisfaction hurts it's painful it's
tedious it's boring it's not interesting
you know but that's the only way you
know and what yeah why did God design
the world like that but you know he did
right you can fight it or wonder why or
you can just kind of get with the
program yeah so Stephen my bad morning
started last night
for some reason I actually think I know
why my wife was having a Val she just
have I was feeling her pain she was she
was dealing with something and I was
feeling it and I had been good all week
and hitting all my goal exercising food
and I was like [__] it there's a peach
cobbler in the fridge
and I did
I really I'm 44. I really think that's
what did it somebody told me about what
sugar does to you hormonally and I'm
just it's just kind of churning in my
belly like a dryer all night and I woke
up and I was just like [__] everything I
was like it was that like I'm so very
well could be I'll tell you why I think
not even the sugar just the knowledge
that you gave into that [__] you know
that's right
and then I tried to exercise couldn't do
it it was like walking through mud
everything was [__] because I had and
that's kind of when you say you were a
loser which is a tricky term only mostly
because Trump said it so much better so
you were losing you felt you weren't
meeting your own goals there's a
momentum there's a sludge momentum
and that sludge momentum that you call
it resistance seems to have a
Consciousness it seems to have this
weird I don't want to get too fancy and
call it demonic but it has this like
dark
demonic yeah you just made a face to say
go ahead yeah it has
an antichrist it has an anti-energy you
know we're talking now about the war of
art we're talking about the concept of
of resistance with a capital R for our
listeners you know that that is that
sort of force that radiates off a a
blank page or anything like that and uh
that will sabotage us it's the voice in
our head that says you're no good you're
unworthy you can't really do this etc
etc you'll lose your friends yeah you
lose it right everything right they
won't feed you there and it makes you
want to eat a peach cobbler it makes you
want to go to the beach you know and yes
you know sometimes like you know who
Seth Godin is I'm sure I don't you don't
ah Seth Godin is he's one of I I of uh
the blogs that I read Ryan is one of
them okay and Seth Godin is is another
okay he's uh he was one of the first
kind of Internet marketers but he's Way
Way Beyond that a real Visionary and in
in
business terms and creative terms check
them out you know Seth Godin how do you
spell that Geo g-o-d-i-n okay here it is
and um
where where was I uh oh yeah he his
concept of what the where this
resistance this negative Force comes
from is the amygdala you know the lizard
brain yes divided that it's whatever
that is it's the oldest part of your
brain the oldest part of your brain the
first part that grew but I don't believe
that because unless a lizard brain is
really smart because resistance
when it produces that voice in your head
that's trying to psych you out or trying
to distract you it's so diabolical and
so intelligent and so nuanced yeah and
so capable of changing shape-shifting
doing all that it it can't just be some
dumb no element like Voldemort and yeah
yeah and I don't know to know where that
comes from is it it's the devil is it
the devil I don't know what it is but
it's for real well you okay on this show
I I always try to get oh that's that's
just honest I do try to get people to it
sounds manipulative but I do I
manipulate people I try to get them to
talk about spiritual things and their
spiritual beliefs and one of the ways
you won't have to work hard you want me
to talk about it but my way in is your
way in too is any they'll say I'm an
atheist but then I'm like well tell me
about your creative process and they'll
start talking yeah yeah so it's really
interesting we have Voldemort resistance
this entity that's inside of us I know
that sounds really scary but it's fine
you're you're dealing with them
constantly so it's not exact yeah so
it's not frightening you don't have to
look out for it it's probably you know
whispering to you as you're listening to
this block yeah going like maybe let's
just watch pornography you know what I
mean because this is a little too
challenging but also one of the things I
love I loved about your book that you
really gave language to is the
anti-resistance so we could call that
the Christ I suppose if that's the
Antichrist Christ or life or Oneness or
universe or flow or whatever
when you are working and this is a
phenomenon anyone that writes certainly
knows you right and then you go for a
drive or you go for a walk and there's
no effort there's no exertion and
there's nothing conscious you don't go
I'm going for a walk that I might have
good ideas but it happened to me on the
ride down
I was mostly driving in silence and this
[__] thing kept going
because I wrote that anxiety joke last
night slept drove
now I'm driving and it goes uh the
opening line is it says this it goes the
opening line is anxiety I have anxiety
thank God and it cut
whole swaths of the treaties doing Cuts
so you point this out you go what is
this
effortless what I mean really why aren't
we all talking about this effortless
uh program that's running in the
background that doesn't deplete your
energy doesn't even seem to be running
maybe it charges your energy right so
it's effort that's the opposite of of
the Diabolical resistance exactly which
is why maybe Christ is a good word for
it it's it's like this birth thing or
the Muse
yes yes I have anything against that The
Fountainhead the spring yeah it's like a
spring and it and and the spring just
like a spring is a naturally occurring
thing it's not being charged by engines
nobody goes shut off the spring spring
and now you're a spring that's the I'm
just saying if we're getting too dark on
the resistance and scaring people
there's this counterpart that is also
available to you so we're back with you
and your vibration and your loser dim
and so you were in that bad momentum the
cobbler momentum peach cobbler not a
Shoemaker yeah your peach cobbler
now your workout sucks now your job
interview sucks now your therapist won't
return your calls so breaking out of
that and it sounds like the answer was
I mean for me it was just years and
years of grinding increment by increment
like I say that I I knew I had to write
my way out of it Pete that was like the
only way right and so it's like
as I talk about in the book at one point
I saved up enough money to work for a
year turned out to be two years and
finally did finish a book didn't you
know didn't crap out at the end now the
book never sold
and neither do the one after that never
sold but that was kind of an increment
back from that loserdum you know at the
so I do think
a lot of the [__] that's out there
now sort of tells you oh you uh you
achieve an insight and everything is
groovy from then on but I don't think
that's the truth like for me
that was like two years of grinding
grinding it was fun but it was grinding
grinding grinding in other words
for you to say to yourself or for me to
say to myself you know maybe I'm not as
much of a loser as I thought I was
you have to actually have done some work
you know like Robert Greene would say
this you know Ryan's mandatory you know
um yeah he did huh yeah he's great uh
yeah but he's living in Los Feliz right
he lives here or he could have but in
any event yeah you gotta
the way out of it the way back is is
really through work in my opinion
there's magic involved but it's also
really just that's showing up every day
every day for the goddess yeah so so
that finally the you know you will get a
little bit of a graduation notice you
know yeah but it's years and years and
years in my opinion it sounds it's to
try to reduce what you just said so
brilliantly into like fake it till you
make it but there's something about like
work it till you jerk it maybe
something like right but of course once
you start to do to do that to get on
that path of work yeah
there's no ending point it's not like oh
four years from now you get a degree you
start to do this this is the rest of
your life you know this is still like
you know take you out feet first right
but that's reality that's what we were
talking about before you know that
somehow God designed this world that you
gotta you gotta work you gotta grind and
you gotta suffer I mean it's the Garden
of Eden right where he casts Adam and
Eve out and says you know henceforth
shalt thou eat thy bread in the sweat of
thy face you know James yeah and you
know what you know what I like about the
Garden of Eden is we had a hand in it we
the way I interpret that story is we
were perfect Oneness in the garden and
we elected to play a game but it was us
an aspect of God us yes decided to eat
the apple by our choice the the snake is
us too the snake is our voice I agree
and it says eat the apple but it was us
we wanted to listen to a naughty snake
is there anything more exciting than
listening to a naughty snake that's we
we connect to that yeah that's the first
time you heard that story you want
you're like oh I hope they eat this the
apple as soon as God says don't eat the
apple you're like I hope they eat the
apple because you know there's something
in our existence right here and now all
this insanity and pain and up and down
and and all the goodness is hiding on
the other side of work we know that's
what happened like a deal was struck
yeah that we could know pleasure but
they're like but if you want to know
pleasure you need to know separation and
if you have separation that means you
have pain you should be a rabbi Pete you
really you got into this thing I'm not
really going for it I'm enjoying this
chat let me ask you dude are most Comics
or comedians no going deep into [__]
like that it's our answer I mean I think
I think about George Carlin or people
like that that they were they were you
know
um
they would go deep deep deep deep deep
they just wouldn't uh maybe not do it on
on stage but the jokes came from
someplace deep for sure I completely
agree and I I I've said this a million
but I think it's weird that more
comedians aren't interested that they
sort of stopped right it's all [__]
ah yeah you don't want to be at the
table
but I'm like the the ultimate Way of not
being at the table is to like really get
into it you know what I mean you go so
far past the fundamentalist or the
literalists or whatever it might be that
you you can't even see them in your rear
view anymore but you get all the juice
that was drawing us to these things in
the first place it's confusing to me and
I appreciate you noticing I appreciate
you seeing me well yeah thank you you
should be a rabbi or think about it it's
not too late it's not too late no
there's there's uh there's there's room
for that stuff what one of the great
things about podcasts like if Carlin had
had a podcast you would have we would
have records yeah yeah I mean I feel
like if Bill Hickson had a podcast I I
feel like it would have saved these guys
but but Hicks thrived and flowed in a
way maybe true yeah I think he was made
to be a podcaster even more than a
comedian like he should have just been
recording himself how he felt every day
Ah that's how I feel and I think the
road sort of squashed him uh as it will
okay so you wrote your way out of it
we're talking about well we're talking
about resistance and and the
anti-resistance
can I give you an example of a
resistance and you can comment on it
sure because I don't remember this being
in your book
but my one wonderful wife Val is writing
a movie and it's a wonderful movie and
it's her first movie and I think she is
destined like her thing is to direct it
I can see because she she doesn't write
like me I mean I'll put angle on and all
these things like but she's writing the
music she's saying the shots like I'm
like this is not normal this is a
director this is how Paul Thomas
Anderson writes for himself he puts in
all these shot notes and stuff you
should direct it and she's I can see my
little nine believing that and I even
imagine the the headphones on her on her
shoulders and I'm like wait a minute I
can see it yeah I really can so she was
working on it and she when she's writing
she feels alive and in the flow and
exactly what you describe and then she
also teaches dance and then this
opportunity came about to uh possibly
take over a dance studio and take right
I'm smiling yeah yes you're smiling yeah
buddy if we didn't go like waiter should
we do this like now I'm instead of
rehearsing this is Val she directed this
beautiful movie called this now I'm
going like oh yeah my wife owns the
dance studio in town and it costs this
much money and and there's all these
like sort of businessy things which I'm
like I don't think should like that but
she got very interested in it and I was
being supportive
and then she came to the conclusion that
it was resistance that it was another
see this is the intelligence oh yes like
it will talk about that it will come for
you
in these ways it comes like shrouded in
good news like good news you know you're
absolutely right Pete that that's not in
the war of Art and it should have been
in the war of art yeah and it's so true
that resistance is so diabolical and
somehow somehow I don't know has control
in the world yes that like if you're on
a path like like your wife has torched
the movie yeah somehow resistance can
produce in the real world
a quote-unquote opportunity that is
actually the death of her dream right if
she says yes to this dance studio
that's a [__] catastrophe you know
and God knows how that works it's got to
be the devil I don't know but uh you're
very you're it's great that you're so
supportive of her and that you get it
and you see what you know her potential
that unrealized potential yet yes and
yeah but it is so true that resistance
will tempt you you know it's like um for
me I I've worked a couple of times or
maybe two or three times in advertising
right which is kind of a sellout sort of
a job to save money so I could go write
a book every time I was ready to go
leave they would offer me a promotion
you know or whatever it was do it before
you and
and I who knows what is there like the
devil putting an idea in your boss's
mind I don't know what's going on but
you always have to sort of confront that
like because the other thing about this
I know I'm blathering on this is what I
was hoping for but these quote-unquote
opportunities always make great sense so
that if you talk to your friends who are
like trying to wish you well oh you know
dance studio is really a good idea I
mean you made me like money it's a
realistic thing right and and you and
your head are going geez should I do
this I mean it but it's just resistance
in the end it's so diabolical the
practicality of it is the dev it's the
details where the devil is hiding it's
like month to month it'd be like an
income coming in yeah oh imagine if we
had this many people it would be this
yeah and you're just sitting writing for
no yeah like it makes a lot of yeah
sense here's the thing that happened to
me for whatever this is worth this was
like I don't know how many 10 years ago
or something like that I got an offer
from the Getty Museum
where they had like um
they brought in fellows or whatever it
was for a particular thing anyway they
would pay a seven Grand a month they'd
give you actually if you wanted an
apartment they gave you an apartment and
you go up to the Getty they gave you an
office they gave you a research
assistant and the whole idea was here
you can write your book here you don't
have to do anything right and so I
talked to various friends and they all
you got to do this is good for your
resume blah blah blah I took it I hated
it was like the worst thing I ever did I
quit
it was the day I said you know each day
I go you should be liking this Steve
this is a golden and I just finally I
just said this is resistance this is
driving me insane yeah and I was so
happy when I finally drove down a hill
and never went back again this really
synchronistic deliciously ties into what
I was saying about anxiety so my morning
with my daughter put me off center and
this conversation I can feel it as I'm
talking to you I I was charged like a
balloon the hair I was charged by that
conflict and there are so many
situations and as you were talking I was
like oh my god I've done things well
I've had this movie idea for 10 years I
wrote you an email and I was like the
war of art I'm on like page 160 or so I
I'm it's too long it's great yeah you
should go back and change it I write too
much I I'm like I'm one of those people
that puts an ellipses and that's the
whole line like does that need to be
there there it doesn't
um so I'll trim it down but like I got
through it but I'm realizing for the
past 10 years I've had this movie idea
and some of the things that have
[__] me up were no-brainer you have to
do that opportunities yeah and as we're
talking about this
I'm remembering just to give Mike a
shout out I called Mike and I was like
you know I'm doing this thing and I and
it's it's like a nice uh opportunity
and I as I was doing it he was like you
should do it and then as I was doing it
I was like you know I haven't worked on
my movie and
since I've been doing this I thought I
would because the hours were right right
right yeah I was like oh the life would
be nice yeah now money is coming in and
like I should be comfortable enough to
work on my book and this goes back to
the anxiety we should be running towards
dis ease not disease but like we should
be running towards well let me see
something let me interrupt you Define
anxiety for me as you mean it
okay I will
and right away uh something Val says to
me all the time and she goes fear is
excitement without breath it's something
she says to me all the time so that's
what I think I mean fear huh it's fear
yeah now would it be fear of the
creative project that you're that your
heart tells you you want to do is that
so in other words is it resistance in
one way or another it is absolutely see
what's interesting I think I'm getting
into new my resistance is getting very
nuanced I I struggled through uh all
your friends will leave you what do you
think you're better than because I got
through all of that pretty quickly
thanks to an overloving mother I was
like [__] you I am better than all of
you I don't care about any of my friends
and you can all eat my ass like I was
like fine going off but now I think one
of the things
and this is very subtle it goes if you
do it what will you have to kind of like
go I could always do that you know what
I mean because if you do it now it's
done and there is a pleasure to going
well that's nuanced I could always do
that isn't that crazy yeah this is why
it's helpful to talk about these things
because the ego is insane yeah it's
insane yeah and if you let it talk to
you it goes like yeah don't do it
because my ego too just like Ryan says
ego is the anime yeah yes he does yeah
when I was reading your uh war of art
have you ever read A Course in Miracles
because I was oh yeah in fact I was into
it for a while can I tell you I couldn't
get very far into it I got to like day
27 or something like that okay reading
your book so was war of art before or
after that it almost doesn't way after
that okay way after that you can tell I
was like oh this dude's red ah the
course because it's so for those you
don't need to know much about A Course
in Miracles but of course in Miracles is
like
uh trying to teach you that there's two
two
choices in your mind and by mine it
means almost more like Soul it's like
your awareness and one is the ego you
can you can use that as your teacher or
you can kind of like you could think of
it as a lens like that can be the lens
you shine your light through or one I
think they would say is um Jesus or the
holy spirit that uses Christian language
you could just say that as your higher
self or your God self or whatever you
want to say and we're always alternating
between these two and it's strategy the
course of strategy is to listen to the
ego it's not to whistle in the dark or
spiritually Bypass or even stop any
Behavior it's like just look at what
you're doing and out it like turn the
lights on on it and listen to it and
you'll start to put it together slowly
that the ego is insane and what does the
ego say It's never enough It's never
enough uh I have to take what you have
somehow I have to like I'm not saying
this is how I consciously feel I'm just
saying there's part of me that's like
somehow how I could uh take uh the war
of Art and have the love that you got
for it for me like that there's an
insane want monster in there that wants
it all for them the teacher sad Guru
says like even if you had the whole
world if you owned the whole world and
it all came to you how long before you'd
want the moon that's just what it did
about a minute and a half yeah about a
minute and a half yeah so you didn't get
very far but do you remember does that
any of that sound familiar I you know I
hadn't seen it through that lens of the
ego you know I mean the course of
Miracle starts if I remember right it
starts like the first lesson is
something like nothing I see is real
right it's nothing else nothing in this
room is is real yeah and means anything
oh mean change is that what they say
yeah yeah so that's kind of uh you know
that sucks you in a little bit I think
that's that's pretty cool you know
because a part of you says to yourself
you know I believe it you know yeah it
doesn't really mean anything it isn't
real and and uh but I hadn't thought of
it from that ego point of view but I'm
certainly a believer in that you know he
doesn't do it hard yeah yeah well the
ego being
I had a real Revelation where I was like
oh when I was talking about the devil
when I was growing up who's the liar
because I grew up Evangelical who's the
liar who's the thief it's the ego we
just called it the devil also you're
gonna this is a fun fact you can use the
rest of your life when Paul St Paul
writes about the flesh he means the ego
that's what the Modern Talking
unfortunately use the word flesh sarks
is the word in Greek I believe
you are look at this stuff man we're
into First Corinthians
but uh like a sheep's herding sheep but
um sarx is the word and we translate it
as flesh but Richard Rohr and others
have taught me that a better word would
be ego but we took it as flesh which
which only hurt this like obsession with
sexuality and like the filth that I'm
just eating [__] farting [__]
thing and it's like no that's a cop-out
like you being embarrassed of your poops
is like so stupid like it's actually way
more Insidious and deeper and that needs
to be exposed and you're actually
stopping here going like oh I had a
boner like [__] off go further you're
actually ravenous and murderous and and
you think invading countries are insane
they're just acting out the same thing
that's in you just writ large and that's
why we love scapegoating and that's why
we love oh that's not me and we just
stand with the innocent and whistle
whistle in the dark ah right man you're
a rabbi
[Laughter]
healthy hydration isn't just about
drinking water it's about drinking water
plus electrolytes which makes sense you
lose both water and sodium When you
sweat so both need to be replaced to
prevent muscle cramps headaches and
energy dips it's also wonderful for
cognitive function overall Wellness this
is how I start my day with what how do I
get magnesium potassium and just the
right amount of sodium into my
bloodstream every single morning I drink
element the amazing hydration drink it's
become a huge part of my wellness
program and a huge and important and
pleasurable part of my morning routine
that I sincerely look forward to I start
every morning with a big glass of water
and a packet of elements I like their
watermelon salt flavor best you just mix
it and you are good to go no sugar or
artificial junk just electrolytes and
great taste and you get that potassium
and you get that magnesium for health
performance and energy it also tastes is
amazing I love drinking it I actually
don't like my water without it I prefer
it with element 10 times more sometimes
at night I'll have a cup of the
chocolate Salt element in hot water
which is incredible and also wonderful
for curbing my appetite when I am
fasting I do intermittent fasting
occasionally I do an entire fast day and
when I'm drinking my element it makes it
so much easier I've given it to so many
friends who love the orange salt flavor
a friend just texted me he went for a
run he came back and drank it it's like
drinking a life-giving Elixir again you
can't just replace the water you got to
get these minerals these elements into
your blood to replenish you to give you
that energy to give you that brain
support and to prevent cramps and
fatigue I love it you have a wonderful
offer here from our friends at element
you go to drink
lmnt.com weird and use promo code weird
they will give you you a free element
sample pack with any order when you
order which is really fun because you
can try all of the flavors and if you're
anything like me get hooked and rotate
and try lots of different ones if
element doesn't exceed your expectations
they have a no questions asked refund
policy you don't even have to send it
back you've got nothing to lose but
support your body support this show go
to drink
lmnt.com where to get your free sample
pack with any purchase that's
drinklmnt.com
weird we're also brought To Us by our
friends at Caraway one of the smallest
simplest things that has added so much
value to our lives is cooking together
as a family and with a four-year-old
we've noticed it's a wonderful parenting
hack that our daughter if she's involved
in the food prep she's so much more
likely to eat it and even try new things
Val and I just got and are in love with
the best looking best cooking new cook
and bakeware from Caraway what is scare
away it's great cookware with no nasty
chemicals that's easy to clean and fun
to use and it also looks great whether
you're late to spring cleaning way way
way late or just about to do some
anytime cleaning they're thoughtfully
designed sets and complementary storage
makes getting and staying organized
easier than ever and you can now save 10
on the full Suite of carrot whey
products from their internet famous
cookware to their newly launched food
storage set care Way's high quality
ceramic coated kitchenware is free of
PTFE such as Teflon it's also free of
lead cadmium and other toxic chemicals
you know aren't safe for you so you know
you are cooking safe and Caraway
kitchenware comes in a variety of chic
Shades and all sets include
complementary easy access storage
solution Ceramics naturally slick
surface means minimal oil or butter for
slide off the pan eggs and easy cleaning
so no chemicals and less oil means
healthier cooking talking and easier
cooking it's so fun over 40 000 people
have raved about their Caraway kitchen
now it's time for you to try for
yourself visit
carawayhome.com weird to take advantage
of this limited time offer for 10 off
your next purchase this deal is
exclusive for weirdos so visit
carawayhome.com weird or use code weird
at checkout Caraway non-toxic cookware
made Modern all right everybody back to
Stephen
okay
in fact I have another guest you should
ask on to your podcast we can talk about
this later he's my Rabbi his name is
Rabbi Mordecai Finley have you ever
heard of Rabbi Findlay he's here in L.A
okay and uh he's uh half Irish half
Jewish uh former Marine
Kung Fu Jiu Jitsu black belt whatever I
don't know what he is and a uh uh PhD in
ethical psychology I think it's called
no and he's done a million kind of
videos that are sort of teaching videos
you know an hour long class but just a
wonderful guy and really into I mean
he'll go deep deep deep yeah so we'll we
can write that down yeah I'm panicking
yeah I have to spell Mordecai but yeah
I'm mortified uh okay so it's
interesting
talking about uh Ryan and you I was
interested in your feelings on
masculinity you mentioned the Marines
you were a Marine
a lot of your approach Val is a deeply
feminine uh woman
and when she reads the war of art she
goes like it's it's very masculine and
I'm like yeah it is like that's what I
really love about it I'm just wondering
what your relationship as I read about
your youth
and how hard it was and long-haul
Trucking and [__] living in your van
and all of that stuff
and I'm over here I'm like what must you
think of us complaining that the Wi-Fi
is out in the Starbucks or whatever it
is but I'm just interested in like how
this day and age like masculinity and
men in general we're learning we're kind
of like learning and evolving but I'm
wondering where you find it useful oh
that's a great question well first of
all let me say that
we're talking about resistance we're
talking about anxiety fear whatever that
and doing the hard stuff and not going
with the peach cobbler
and in order to do that to live that
that hard life which we for the rest of
our lives we have to summon some sort of
force of mental toughness or whatever
you want to call it yeah and I think it
can be masculine or feminine in in
practice the most
warrior-like individual I can think of
is a mother I mean if you think about uh
a mother will lift a Buick with her bare
hands if her child is underneath that
right or go into a burning building to
save her child and in fact that when we
talk about art or creativity or what is
it except bringing forth new life right
it's being pregnant it's bringing forth
something like that so I do think male
or female the male side would be the
kind of a the warrior sort of ethic you
know the virtues of a warrior and that
kind of thing the female side to me is
is the mother that the nurturing the
loving the idea of total selflessness
that you the mom will give everything
including your life to protect that life
within you you know and so I think
whether it's male or female we have to
summon some no [__] strength yes to
face this devil yes day after day after
day and and uh and faith has a lot to do
with it now I'm not talking religious or
anything but we do have to believe in
that creative force that you were
talking about before you know which to
me is like the big bang it's it's
it's part of the cosmos it's part of
existence whatever it is though there is
this devil force of resistance there's
also this Universal creative force that
you heard in your head when you were
driving down here from Ojai this morning
so
anyway that's kind of where I come out
on mail or yeah it's not it's not
masculine or feminine I think it's both
I completely hear that so we have a cold
plunge so does Ryan I think he got maybe
got the same one I have anyway we were
texting about it it's very interesting
uh both we have a little uh
get-togethers at our house and people
are always curious about the cold plunge
and that's one of those things that I
can't shut up about so I'm always like
really don't ask me about it if you
don't want me to talk about it for 45
minutes but what happens and I'm very
proud of this we're not like drinkers uh
so our parties are very PG but what
happens instead of like doing shots or
other like Feats of Strength is people
will get in the cold plan which is
really fun men and women and I do notice
that in general men tend to be a
thousand times more interested in
getting in it and that's neither really
here nor there that's interesting I
thought you were gonna say the opposite
no the women do get in it and some of
the women absolutely rock it and you
know both do well but I I've always
considered it to be pouch Envy when I
get it I'm like this is because we don't
have babies this is only because we
don't well I think that's true because
creativity yeah
but I the so I coach the people when
they get in the Coldplay I go uh first
things first you're gonna get in at your
feet and it's going to be really cool at
your feet and you're going to want to
stop and the first thing you need to
realize is if you get your whole body in
it it's better because you get
overwhelmed and your body doesn't know
where to feel pain so you feel no pain
but if you're just getting your feet
your feet are going to hurt like hell so
get in it doesn't that just sound like
the law of the universe yeah I think it
is true absolutely get in it the whole
[__] way or it's gonna punish you
yeah get in yeah and then I go the first
thing we're gonna do is ever thought
about that that's why coal plunges I
think are so uh addictive yeah yes and
there's something universally true about
them like cosmically true about them two
smile because you're not going to want
to your lips are gonna turn blue and you
[__] hate it I go you have to smile
and tell yourself I love it you have to
say well I'm like this is to life this
is the opposite of dying in a nursing
home this is like the most invigorating
thing and then our goal isn't to stay in
for two minutes or one minute or
anything our goal is one long slow
exhale because you're gonna be going and
then it's just like just all and I just
go just look at me because they all
close their eyes and I go just look at
me and go
what does that sound like Lamaze that's
exactly what I did with my wife when she
was giving birth I go look at me and
breathe and that's why everybody's
getting in this cold punch it's the same
exact thing but this is why Bagger Vance
is true this is why your work on the
resistance is true it's like get in slow
down breathe go through not around you
can't go around and if you give up your
day is [__] and if you stay in your
day is golden yeah
why did why did God make the universe
that way right that you got to get into
his freaking you know 32 Degree whatever
it is yeah plunge yeah yeah that goes
back to the Garden of Venus what we were
saying it's like we wanted and this is
very to me of Course in Miracles is the
Garden of Eden and the prodigal son just
from much more extreme Vantage points
but the first one is God wanted us all
together in him or in God as one thing
and this is all metaphor none of it's
gonna it's not gonna be perfect it's
just words but it's like there was part
of us that was like wouldn't it be nice
to be separate just as an experiment
just like as an innocent little game
what if we were separate and then bam it
all happened in fact the whole of it
happened in an instant it's already over
it's already done but here we are kind
of worming our way through it yeah and
that's the prodigal son we just we we
left home we squandered our inheritance
our inheritance being perfect Oneness to
gamble and have sex and uh remember he's
Jewish and he works with the pigs so
that's like to degrade ourselves we want
it we want it just like movies we want
to be degraded we want to be
disrespected we want to be wronged we
want so we can fight for vengeance so we
can come back and all of it and then the
the game ends when you go like wait I
could just go back to my dad's house
please tell me when we ate the apple
what we really wanted to do it was like
God had
all the creative power he was the
creator and we were the created right
and if we stayed within this world where
everything was given to us we were like
children right but we said whether we
realized it or not how about if we
create something and we started to get a
little spark of the power that only God
had and that's why he got so pissed off
at us I think it's like you crossed this
line [__] well you know can I
deeply excited to interject because of
Course in Miracles would say God can't
be mad at us God's perfect love and
Oneness we thought he was mad at us so
we developed the ego and the ego is is a
creature of Duality and it says come
with me or God will kill you and we go
okay it's like Schwarzenegger come with
me if you want to live so we sided with
the ego and then the world of the ego
was developed and that's why this whole
thing is killer be killed that's why
this whole thing is chaotic that's why
this whole thing is random that's why
this whole thing is afraid because we
think God is trying to kill us so we
have to kill him first which we think we
did but that sin that guilt and that
fear comes into past present future and
it creates this whole [__] thing
which is why the Course in Miracles is
the only thing that I found that doesn't
just explain suffering but goes like
this is this is why it happened like we
did this and we're afraid of this so the
whole thing follows that the law of that
initial Choice very interesting but the
solution is to go God's not mad at us
how could perfect love be mad at us
[__] stop it like stop it
I was just very excited to say that
but I do think that that we're trying to
get back to the Garden don't you think
absolutely you know as but not as we
were originally uh in other words
unconscious created beings right but as
conscious co-creative beings yeah yeah
and get back to that somehow to get back
to that Oneness to God completely
whatever that whatever that may be which
I think when we're writing a joke or
we're being we're doing anything
creative
we are doing that which God Alone does
yes right
agreed and that's pretty amazing you're
coming into your inheritance you're kind
of like you're reflecting the light of
God's creation yeah yeah yeah which in a
way I think has to be God's idea from
the beginning whether we knew it or he
knew it or whatever yeah I don't think
any of it's a mistake or an error but
here's here's where no I don't think so
it's interesting why don't we go back to
the father or to God it the course would
say because we think we killed him the
ego says you killed him if we live in
Duality and God is Oneness you must have
ended Oneness to become Duality so you
murdered him and that's why we kill our
food and that's why we kill each other
and that's why we project our guilt onto
you and that's why we can't stop judging
each other to make ourselves innocent I
go well Steven's an idiot he's selfish
and great all the things that I that I
am so I can be innocent and you'll go to
hell and I'll go to heaven it's all this
like scapegoating projection and then
the bhagavad-gita comes at it from a
whole other aspect of
Krishna God saying Arjuna doesn't want
to fight
doesn't want to kill these other people
Krishna says to him
yes I do want you to kill those other
people because death is not real and he
says to Arjuna I have killed them all
already so it won't be you doing it
which I don't really understand it's the
opposite of the sort of the Christian
concept right but um so the whole
killing thing yeah you know is embraced
in some crazy way in in this Hindu
tradition you know yeah that you know
the destroy I am whatever it is the
destroyer of worlds yeah whatever that
was that Oppenheimer said yeah
um
anyway I come as death or something was
that yeah something like that yeah
Katie's gonna google it for us we'll all
know when we see that yeah Nolan movie
anyway we're getting deep here you gotta
have Rabbi Findlay here I think you're
doing wonderful I mean you're you're
lighting me up the rest I just know the
rest of the day is going to be great
because we did we went to this depth
together what do we got
I am become death the destroyer of
worlds yeah it gets heavy see that's why
but that's not a bad thing yeah that's
the way Christian's looking at well in
our culture death is the absolute worst
yes Abomination and this is wrong
something crazy about that I think you
know ramdas right there his pictures up
there oh that's wrong he used to say
it's like he died 88 he died when he was
88. um
he's like we run out and the TR the
leaves are turning orange and we paint
them green like that's our whole society
and he goes our religion is staying
alive
and the high priests or the doctors and
the churches or the hospitals and it's
like we can't look at it we put makeup
on our corpses we we put them in suits
and we visit them and eat cheese like we
can't [__] handle it but I always
think that it's I quote it all the time
but it's in the day changes go no it's
an yeah it may be the book of the doubt
but
um maybe that's the same thing I've
never even known it goes uh you should
have been born back in the 60s
you know 20 years old in 1969 wouldn't
that have been no maybe I was
maybe you knew me man
you may be my son and I don't even know
but it says those that find their way in
the morning can gladly go in the evening
but we don't have that we have just keep
it going
this whole world this is a dark thought
but this whole world runs on not me not
yet yeah true other people are dying
other people are sick not me not yet not
me not yet another day my passport got
stamped again not more hamburgers more
movies more more uh sex more Skittles
but it's like it can't be that skittless
Skittles are great but it can't be that
because the day you die will be just
like today it'll be another moment and
the quality of your Consciousness in
that moment is I think what matters how
you've learned to embrace all adversity
including the cessation of your
breathing is the whole thing it can't
just be Skittles and [__] it can't
now if if we go back to what we were
talking about before about the ego and
the self
and uh I'm gonna lose my train of
thought here but um
it's the old thing of Are We Spiritual
Beings having a material existence or
are we uh you know material things
having having a having a spiritual
existence sin and uh
if if that's if we Are Spiritual Beings
having a material existence and the ego
is this bad thing then
are we simply in Exile from whatever
World exists beyond the curtain and in
that case maybe we shouldn't be so
afraid of that world you know whatever
that is gradually and maybe we've yeah
maybe we've just talked ourselves into
it it's the it's the ego running rampant
you know and convincing us yes that uh
you know there's like a great quote uh
have you ever read um
there's actually a penguin paperback
called the last days of Socrates and it
has like the three or four dialogues
that Plato wrote when Socrates had been
convicted and was in the cell and was
waiting to die are you familiar with us
at all uh it's it's really amazing you
know because here was like one of the
smartest guys that ever lived the most
highly evolved facing his own death and
the way it worked was he was in this
this prison but all of his friends could
visit him and they were there all day
long you know finally at night the
Jailer would kick him out but you know
all of his disciples and acolytes and
stuff like that and it went on for you
know a couple of weeks or something like
that while he was waiting I'll again get
wonky on you here they couldn't execute
him he had been convicted he was
supposed to drink the hemlock but they
couldn't execute him because there was a
festival where a boat had gone you know
the the spiritual boat with the maidens
and The Virgins had gone to the island
of delos I think Apollo and they
couldn't execute anybody until a boat
came back and of course there's no
radios in those days so nobody knew when
the boat was going to come back so they
were just sort of waiting and it was
like each day would go by and it was
like where's the boat they can't execute
you anyway
he says to uh Socrates says to his his
um the day comes and he's taken the
hemlock and uh the boys yeah the poison
is going to kill him right and uh he
says to his friends are all weeping
enough said he says and so we part my
friends you to live and I to die
but who knows who can say which one is
the best of these two of these two
things wow and then they all they all go
and wow he goes on so and of course he's
absolutely right yeah who's to sing
who's to say yeah nobody's ever uh come
back yeah and been like hey yeah I mean
that's debatable to certain Traditions
but yeah and I'll give you one other
small thing in here please there's he
Socrates you know they're waiting for
the boat and they have no idea when the
boat's going to come back and Socrates
has a dream
and in the dream a woman in white greets
him on the road and she says to him in
three days to the pleasant land of Thea
which is a place in Greece a beautiful
place shalt thou go and sure enough so
he he said to his friends the boat will
be here in three days and of course it
was and but what the maiden and white or
the lady in white said was you know to
the pleasant land of Thea shalt thou go
so for whatever that's worth we don't
know yeah nobody does gladly go in the
evening yeah yeah it reminds me of when
Romano maharshi was a great Indian Saint
was dying his devotees were also around
him and said don't go they were saying
heal yourself ah do a miracle and he
said don't be silly where could I go
and I've had some pretty far out talk
about the 60s psychedelic experiences
where the takeaway was beyond
I just can't articulate it but beyond a
doubt
Thomas Merton said this too uh
you don't go to heaven
it's not like leaving and traveling you
you come back into the essence of what
you always were and that was my
experience is it's not like a a rocket
like Mighty Mouse to another dimension
you're already there there's just all
this muck kind of confusing you which
didn't Jesus say the Kingdom of Heaven
is within you right yeah is that what he
meant do you did you interpret that
absolutely that's how I interpret it
it's the Kingdom of Heaven is here and
men do not see it it's this idea and
that's why I think you and I when we're
writing when we're
great music great art great movies
honestly it sounds like well how could
that be I think anything that helps you
lose yourself you vanish but you're
still there I think there's something
deeply spiritual about an audience
listening to the same music it's like
Consciousness is shared yeah musicians
yeah with each other that's why it makes
it so yeah their ego has gone away if
you're in the audience your ego's gone
right you're just in the music you don't
even know what you're thinking about and
what a great pleasure and that's a
little reflection
of our original state or of the garden
yeah and it's also really interesting
that it's music we're talking about here
with which also mathematics and music
are like the same thing you know and
they're sort of supernal you know beyond
beyond right the music of whatever the
Spheres or whatever right mathematics
being the language of wow of uh
existence whatever Einstein said you
know right wow we're getting pretty deep
here you know is this what we were going
to do here I thought it was a comedic
yeah I always say we stopped trying to
be funny about 10 years
it's not really a Chuckle Hut anymore
but I I wouldn't have it any other way
I'm trying this I'm trying to remember
it was Beethoven that said something
similar it was it was like if people
could understand I'm badly paraphrasing
it's like if people could understand
one Symphony that I wrote like fully
they would know God basically it was it
was very and I'm sure he's right well
you said the first lesson of Course in
Miracles uh this blank doesn't mean
anything this cup doesn't mean anything
Eckhart Tolle said if you could
understand just that one lesson that's
the whole thing is that you're a meaning
making machine I I'm Discerning between
the atoms between us and the atoms that
are me and the atoms that are you and
going like these are three things the
air you and me
but it's also one thing and it's very
scary to lose meaning we can praise our
ego too and go like thanks for helping
and keeping us calm yeah yeah it's a
little too much to go like this Stephen
it helps me to call you Steve yeah yeah
it's a little we can't live in a
psychedelic world all the time that's
right because we're just you know we
have to get up and fry some eggs you
know for breakfast you know and that's
where the ego you know proves its value
to it that's right but it's funny this
is going back a couple ideas ago but
again to talk about the scapegoating
we were talking about
if you achieve things the ego stops
existing like if you find your flow and
and start
seizing your potential the ego gets
shaky that's one way to explain why
resistance exists it goes like let's
keep you small let's keep you manageable
yes and that's what the ego does and
then I I think it made me think of
people that are like well America just
wants to keep you consuming like it just
wages Wars and it just wants you to buy
stuff
and I'm like that's what the ego does
it's the same thing like stop acting
like it's so exotic the reason it's so
offensive to us is because that's what
we're doing to ourselves not me not yet
just keep buying yeah just keep coming
and just keep eating just keep sleeping
and I'll run the show that's the shadow
government that's the real Illuminati
yeah is the thing that's going like pay
no mind to the man behind the curtain
but there's this greater inheritance
Jesus has all these great Parables about
it but one of them that I love is it's
like the man that uh was in a field and
he found a treasure buried under the
ground so he went to the people selling
the land and bought the field knowing
that he could get the treasure so he
sold everything that he owned to buy the
field knowing that there was a treasure
that's powerful you don't even need to
really fully understand it but it's like
there's something somewhere it's in you
it's buried like a treasure that's worth
giving up everything for but we're too
busy
it's one of the reasons I'm not too
worried about AI is because our desires
I know our desires are so insane they're
all respect based they're spatial
they're psychological I want you to
respect me I want you to tell me I'm
important I can't see a machine going
like why didn't you tell me I was cool
you know what I mean but it may surprise
you you think it might you know I don't
know I don't know
I don't even want to think about it it's
too scary to me yeah oh really yeah yeah
it's possible as long as it's not it's
not in space though like we want to work
and Achieve and humiliate our our foes
and win so we can have a house by an
ocean right AI doesn't want a house by
an ocean it wants it wants literal
electricity it wants electricity so
that's the great I wonder about it you
think it'll go like I don't understand
what it is anyway but maybe it will want
a house by the ocean you know maybe it
will want uh you know uh
dominion over whatever we want those
things because an Ocean looks like
resources that Keep Us Alive like we're
so stupid that we go like water
Commerce
Recreation hydration a computer isn't
gonna go like I just need to know where
the Farms are like it doesn't care well
I don't know I hope you're right I hope
you're right uh well for the record
I've always spoke up in your defense
tell me just some good go what you have
something no go ahead go ahead give me
some good old-fashioned
off the I wasn't planning on asking you
this but here you are a man I respect I
feel like I would want to be asked this
question give me some give me some
wisdom give me some of those things that
have carried you through we've covered a
lot of them so don't feel like you owe
me anymore yeah we've hit everything
yeah but if you have some of those
things I I'm I'm 44 people listening are
20 22.
there's things that you might assume
they know but give me we just have so
few people that have been there done
that and can articulate it are there
little mantras that you've carried
little maxims things that people have
impressed on you I know this is in the
book as well would you share just some
totally aside from you from your work
just what is that life wisdom that that
you that's changed your life
well I'm a Believer okay I'll try and
I'm a Believer in the Muse the goddess
the goddess who inspires artists right
and I'm definitely a believer that life
exists on at least two levels we're here
on the material Level we're talking
about the ego or the flesh that dies but
there's another level above above us and
that's where jokes come from and where
movies come from and and the Ninth
Symphony comes from and basically I
think
our purpose at least my purpose and I'll
say that to anyone creative and I
believe that's everybody
is to
believe in first believe in that other
level
and then find a way to reach it and the
way to reach it in my experience is
through work is through
sitting down and grinding you know
sitting down like Beethoven sits staying
at the piano and sort of tunes into the
cosmic radio station that's the thing up
there and in order to
to be able to do that he has to First
sort of
make himself an instrument make himself
a vessel make himself a conduit make
himself someone who
possesses the skills I'm blathering on
here but I'll give you the full the full
dose you would prefer that I keep
laughing who possesses the skills
thinking of Beethoven yes he can play
the piano he can you know write the
music but he also has the skills to sit
day after day after day whenever when
he's deaf when nobody when everybody
else thinks he's crazy
um and to serve the goddess and to reach
that that higher level and that I think
is
I mean that's the way I try to live my
life yeah and it's the the weird part of
it is is that it's not cinematic it's
not glamorous it's tedious it's boring
it's a montage of the movie at best and
it's it's digging you know it's digging
with a shovel you know yeah so that's my
I think people think today young people
think today they can do one video that
goes viral and they'll become Kim
Kardashian you know yeah and the world
just doesn't work that way isn't it fun
to think in defense of Kim Kardashian
how hard and how much effort she's
putting in yeah yeah I'm sure if we
really knew her she works like a dog I'm
sure she does that's really fascinating
and what a brilliant truly brilliant
answer I'm saying what is your life
wisdom and you're saying find a higher
calling believe in a purpose and that is
like
what I see so missing
I'm I think people are trying for it but
they don't know where to find and let me
say one other final thing please that
whatever that calling is it's Unique to
you and unique to me it's not that you
can do anybody else's your comedy
or you're whatever it is that you're
doing the movie that your wife is
writing yeah is unique to you and unique
to her nobody else could do it that's
that's the calling yeah so the answer
sort of is what it's like we were born
with it we were born with a seed inside
us you know with this
sense of humor or sense of whatever it
is and
all we have to do is find that all we
have to do is open ourselves up to it
like um Joseph Campbell said follow your
bliss it sounds like a you know a kind
of a phony baloney bumper sticker Mantra
but it's really true yeah what do you
love what makes you feel great and
follow it and that aligns with what you
were given so Richard Roy says the the
meaning of life is to humbly and proudly
I like that because it's a paradox
homily and proudly return what you've
been given right okay that's good I like
this isn't that right yeah beautiful so
what I hear you saying is something I
say to people when they ask
it's like maybe it's not a movie store
like [__] it stop it maybe it's not a
movie star like sometimes what's written
on your bones to do
is just so happens to be what the
culture values above all else which is a
movies
okay sometimes it's Tom Cruise sometimes
it's absolutely not and we need to get
more it's a lack of imagination thinking
I'm gonna go to Hollywood and be this or
I'm going to be a rock star like there
are other options and you need to
broaden the menu of fulfilling deep
important very well lives right yeah but
too many of us are just going like well
I guess I have to go viral like Kim
Kardashian yeah it's like there are Kim
Kardashian levels of all these different
places but we don't we don't see them
modeled yeah yeah yeah I'll give you one
small example that I've thought about on
this subject I have a lifelong friend my
friend Ruthie she's basically never
worked she's uh
um she's been married I know three times
I guess and uh
according to any of the sort of movie
star things she would not be able to
check that box but what she is in her
family and her extended family which is
a pretty big one she's the one you go to
when the [__] hits the fan you know she
holds it now there's no role for that
that's right you know there's no label
for they don't say that's not like
astrophysicist but that's just what
you're really saying Pete yeah that that
we need to have the imagination say
that's just as valid if not more valid
yeah than any of these other you know
Elon Musk or whatever it is that's right
so and of course there are a million you
know
I don't want what you call it roles yes
that's right are not valued dude the
society doesn't give you a medal for it
they don't tell the story about it
they're absolutely vital that is okay so
it's like I love that you said valid
because I made me think of Val I was
sort of making her laugh telling the
story you mentioned that we live in Ojai
we have this beautiful Balanced Life
it's filled with like quiet and beauty
and and like the greatest compliment
people ask Val what's it like being
married to a comedian she said I I can't
tell other than we laugh but I'm not
like some insane person scrolling on the
walls or whatever because we've achieved
this balance that's right for us it's
not that is not the fix for everybody
but we found the thing that worked for
us and it happens to be the exact thing
that works for me which is great so I
told Val there's a little story where I
was like
I was just making her laugh just
appreciating her being like I was like
this insane monkey in the woods and I
had acorns and I spent all day just
throwing acorns in a little hole
it's all I did and nobody bothered me
and I just got really good at throwing
acorns in a little hole but was I
fulfilled or happy no I was pretty
insane like there were moments of wow I
really nailed that Acorn but like I had
been doing it so long nobody even asked
me like how many acorns are in that tree
this is not a metaphor for money by the
way it's just a skill how many acorns
are in that tree have you done that long
enough like are you good enough at that
but she came along like a woodland
fairy goddess a love genius is what she
is someone who understands and
appreciates what a home can be I know
that sounds very general oh no that's
great but a home can be what a life can
be and she [__] rescued me and we
took the acorns again it's not a
metaphor for money it was a skill and we
were like this can be part of it but I
can be so stubborn and blindered on that
I without her so when I were biking
around our beautiful town at Sunset I
get emotional going like I wouldn't have
done this I'd be living in a cop's
apartment Venetian blinds and the
mattress on the floor just saving money
for who knows what I'm [__] dying so
is there is that like a a heralded
choice not not culturally there's not a
lot of movies about people like this but
it's the most [__] beautiful and her
life is good her life is beautiful and
not because she's married to a famous
person because she knows balance she she
understands Harmony she understands
friendship she taught that to me and
then in my small way I teach her
ambition I'm driving so these two
flavors the skin and this Yang came
together that's gorgeous but nobody's
sitting around going like I could just
or if they did they would say just if I
could just be a vowel [__] you'd just be
about just be a Pete and strive to be a
vowel it's under celebrated under
recognized yeah all these and there's
God bless you and God bless Val that's
an incredible thing you know we all need
Val we should end on that note right
there cut
it doesn't get any better than that you
know God bless you I can't I'm so struck
by your humility you've let me blab so
much this hour and you and when I wasn't
you were going I'm sorry for our
conversation right yeah
yeah but yeah I I see the I don't wanna
I'll just say it I see the work you've
done on yourself and it's great it's
like hanging out with a giant Bell thank
you so much
you can ring when you want to yeah but
the rest of the time there's just all
this space for everyone else beautiful
this is great that you and Val have this
thing you know God bless the both of you
thank you it's great thank you yeah I
appreciate it thanks for having me here
Pete you know and it's been waiting for
being the dude that you are you know
well everyone don't read Rabbi friendly
I'm gonna have them on Mordecai Yeah Boy
Morty don't let Mordecai throw you off
you know it's more than more the Finland
part you know yeah he's more of an
Irishman yeah he's a redheaded dude you
know and uh oh I can't yeah yeah he's
great well I'll be better for it when he
comes on thank you what a privilege to
say thank uh face to face thank you for
the war of Art thank you for government
cheese thank you for everything you've
done and thank you for this time okay
great you know thanks Pete thanks for
having me on here would you say keep it
crispy it's right over your shoulder in
case you want to read it like a cute
card okay
crispy
my neck won't turn that far yeah you did
you don't have to look at it I like that
you I saw you realize why keep it crispy
what's that all about it just started as
a joke kind of ah but you know we've
been talking about this whole time
keeping it crispy ah flow ah open okay I
like that crisp do the work ah get in
the cold plunge all right thank you
David great
oh yeah
[Music]